today we're gonna walk through just
dockerizing a python app um it's gonna
be some basics and then we'll go up to
kind of some mid-level
stuff while we do this
uh yeah so this app it's kind of a
i've been involved in the python
developer group for a long time uh one
of the longer standing elements so we we
have our own bot obviously like a lot of
groups on discord and slack and
everything
um
and i keep playing playing with the idea
of using new python features to build a
new version of it um so this bot is very
much in the infancy um
but what it does is sorry let me make
sure it's actually added to the team
um
the whole point is i want it to be
composable for other people to be able
to use it
either in their app directly or to
and it's going to pop up the wrong slack
um
either in their app directly or just add
plugins if they want
so that's what we're going to be doing
so it just does a simple like
quote a stock kind of thing uh for now
and that's based on plugins
and so we're going to start through
let's see i kind of i'll publish all
this obviously afterwards um but one big
thing with demos i always kind of
i get lost sometimes in the commands
people run you know uh so i made a make
file which is just just uh
something simple so afterwards we can
reflect back and see oh this is how we
ran different things
but we'll not focus on that in a moment
so getting started um
this spot requires uh redis to be up
and you can
so this gets broken
uh and so to do that you can either run
redis on your host or run it in uh
something else like online or in a
container
so for fun
we could show we can run redis just
locally here uh and we're gonna be able
to let's see
we can test this this port oh my
sorry about that
that's the wrong one
so right now i can't access this this is
running a docker but right now the way
the networking is set up they isolate it
from my host system so we're going to
kind of gloss over this a little bit
right now
but this network is separated from my
host by default
but since docker has its own networking
layer
you can
actually
you actually connect to
it in the container here so i'm pointing
my fingers inside of my mouse
i used to do these in person sometimes
so yeah so you can actually link these
containers
to
access redis or postgres or
rabbitmq whatever kind of stuff you're
running uh your app
with um so in this case i'm actually
gonna restart this one with the port
allowed
um so we could we could run a cli from
my host which i don't actually think i
have installed oh i do
uh so now we can actually see that and
the block can
connect to it
uh so that's right again um
so this now that we've exposed the
network we can see it from our host but
um we kind of run into an issue with
pretty much any programming language
you're gonna work with a runtime
um
where it's hard to share this stuff
especially when you talk about like
python and i don't know how many of the
folks here
are python people or 100 python or just
partially but dependency management
python has long been
kind of a pain point for us
we have like pip-m
poetry
um
obviously just raw pip which is what i
tend to use and so if i want to share
this app or develop it with my
co-workers or you know the open source
community on our on our slack group
um
it's hard it's really hard uh so
you have to know you've set up a virtual
environment you have to know which
requirements to install you have to know
all this stuff just just to contribute
and if you're like coming in popping in
want to help out on a project
that's a lot of overhead just to write a
line of code and contribute it
on github or wherever you might be
so uh one nice thing here
and what docker really enables us to do
is we can make
a shareable image that people can use
to to build and run their apps
sorry grab a little coke here
so
what we're going to do let's walk
through just setting this up this is all
stuff you probably do
on your desktop or laptop normally
um
but we can automate all the steps for
somebody else instead of like giving
them a make file like i have here
um so we're gonna do kind of just the
quick and dirty docker file and we'll
walk through each instruction
um
just to get it going
so you always have a from
and then you just give it a base image
and i always like the alpine images
because they're tiny which is awesome
for download speed deployment speed all
that uh there's some nuances and the
differences but
we'll we can talk about that later if we
have time uh and if not something to
follow and research
so
in doing this we need to
this is optional but you can set like
where you wanna want to work in the in
the container
so all
all steps going forward are in this
context of work of slash app
and then you have to add your
dependencies obviously
and this is where you can see it really
is nice to start trying to remember all
these for this app because sometimes i
forget
um
start off top of the head but uh some
notes obviously but yeah so you can see
let's suppose i send this to somebody
i'm running on windows right now trying
out wsl to see if the linux girl here
can support my daily needs um
but i'm on windows and then i can send
it somebody with mac with this and if
they need to install gcc and g plus plus
and make and
whatever else our app might need you run
into some kind of crazy
headaches i think um because it's like
oh
depending on how their system's set up
it's different and it's not reusable
it's not shareable
um we can copy in our application
then we can run again so run commands
run in the context of the build so this
is when we do docker build
um
not when the container is actually
running
let's see requirements
we'll do production right away
you don't have to specify this expose
but i have a friend who told me i
thought this was really smart um you can
use it for documentation like if your
app is always going to be running
hopefully on a um a port uh if it's a
web app i suppose it's just a nice way
to document it and it helps with certain
things like traffic which we'll talk
about
and
let's see so i'm just going to type the
moment
wow
it's the hardest part demos is typing in
front of people
yeah
all right let's see
all right
so
like i said everything runs in the
context of the build until you hit this
one and this is just what the command is
going to be in your app and your
container when it starts
and hopefully this doesn't take super
long to build
uh just as one side note you're if
you're following along or just getting
started with docker um the output may
look a little different than this this
is a new feature
called build kit i don't know a ton
about it yet other than i set the
variable so it looks i like the
formatting a little better but peter you
probably
probably tell me why it's why it's
better
yeah i'll talk a little while it's
running there um
yeah so it's the latest and greatest uh
build engine and it's composable you you
can run it in different places it has
better caching and also does uh
you can do parallel builds so it looks
at your docker file and says oh i can
run these steps
in parallel with these steps
and then at the end it can bring them
back
together it also does like dependency
checking so if you have
multi-stage builds
and you trigger a stage that you want to
build it then knows what that build is
dependent on
and it will only build those
uh dependencies and will won't build
everything that's in your docker file
um oh that's cool
yeah and then the caching is really
a really great feature so it speeds
speeds everything up
um you can pre-load caches and stuff
like that
oh that's very cool
yeah
yeah so i i should have popped out the
c dependency of this one because this
one takes a few extra
seconds
yeah no worries
but um i think one thing i'll gloss over
here um a little bit is so right now
this basic file that we're running is it
it's building a
container that we can ship off to like i
don't know amazon or whatever
or swarm or whatever we want to deploy
with and um
what it does right now is anytime i
change anything this whole build process
so this couple minutes we're waiting um
will run every time if anything changes
in these what are called layers i think
let's
get a little more advanced we'll fix
this docker file in a minute
to talk about those specifically but
um i guess just take me in my word that
every time we rebuild this right now
it's gonna
or every time we try to run this if we
change any code it's gonna rebuild
everything
yeah
i think last time i clocked this was 140
seconds i think but we'll see
here we go
it's going to make me wrong it always
does
of course
got that you got the added little um
talking to me on go to webinar with
picking up a little bandwidth probably
or something
that's my
my
limited knowledge of networking
yeah i actually pruned some of the
system images just so we could show
exactly what people see because another
thing is sometimes i get confused with
when i watch others
it looks a little different here we go
166 172 all right so not bad
um and since we did not
oops sorry
let's see i didn't tag this which is
whatever
running it's harder
all right so you try to run it's in a
boot loop because right now
uh uh
environment variables aren't there
which is something i overlooked while
prepping that part
um
let's see
i put them in secrets so we're gonna
step past that one
actually
yeah
all right so
this
like i said it runs and runs right now
it's boot looping um
but right now it's
we want to be able to access it let's
let's just do a simple one to kind of
show what i wanted to show here
and this is the same same port issue
what this container was or i guess the
bind issue
um
is
in the docker file one thing i did and
this is kind of a funkiness not a
[ __ ] it's just how networking works i
sent this bind address to localhost
running a dev that's usually what you'd
probably do obviously you don't if
you're like at a coffee shop during the
normal world you're not going to want
this expose the whole world just working
your laptop
um
but in docker that'll actually be
isolated to this networking actually
similar to redis when we first started
um that would be visible on my host so i
can't you know hit that locally
um
so from there i think
normally we'd have to link this to the
network similar to that redis cli again
um
so again we have to link these
containers uh so when you're talking
about like a single application it's
kind of something simple where you have
like this you have
um redis and your python app
it's pretty easy to spin these up
manually side by side like this one i
spun up and then
we ran this
um we ran this where we could just run
these locally it's not a huge head
burden to run these side by side where
you start thinking about larger
applications stuff we work on at work
stuff we work on
um
like kind of free time that's a bigger
project or things you want to deploy we
start thinking bigger where you have
background workers like in in the python
world since our our apps are generally
people call them slower um you have your
background workers for mailers and
background jobs all that kind of stuff
it starts to become a huge burden to
share that with people
and so in doing that
to make that simpler we have a tool that
we can leverage called docker compose
and what this does is very aptly named
you can compose a bunch of different
pieces together so in our case
for this specific application
it's
the application itself
and then it's the dependencies um so
redis
uh and so like i said spinning up is
kind of a pain so we can actually make
it even easier by by building a docker
compose file to compose these two things
together
and really just define what our
application needs at any given point
my favorite part
is if you version this and git
which i think you should um with your
application you can actually at any
point in time you can go back six months
ago
and run the app then
um
without without much headache and in
python 2 a big issue that we've talked
about a little bit with dependency
management is
um there's an old adage of like friends
don't let friends use system python and
what that means is you don't install
pip packages or python packages
to the host or to your system python you
always have to put it in some virtual
virtual environment or some other layer
docker that whole idea is removed
because we don't actually have to think
about it
it's totally isolated kind of by default
so yeah well the go ahead
i was gonna say that we got a question
around that so i might as well thought
i'd jump in sorry for stopping you but
so uh michael asks ever use virtual
environments
inside of docker
or always install to the system python
so i think what he's asking and i have
this question too because i'm not a um
you know full-time python developer and
i've seen it both ways right of inside
your actual docker file you install
you're using invo uh a in a virtual
environment inside of
your container when it runs
any thoughts around that
yeah i don't i don't know if i'm
controversial or not but i would say
generally no the big the big reason is
there's nothing else depending on
that python and its dependencies like
there's nothing else generally when you
deploy a container
it should be a process per container and
there's very few exceptions around that
so it's not an absolute but it's a
general rule of thumb
so you're not corrupting the system
python like you would on a host where
you know you're some networking layer
can't resolve like dns because you
changed out the dns resolver for
like a python package
yeah so generally i don't use a virtual
environment in there i think it's an
extra overhead you can uh but i don't
think that it really impacts anything
negatively to not
yeah
that's my thought you know just by
understanding the docker and working
with other uh application programming
languages and and uh containerizing them
right yeah
that would be my default answer is
unless you have a
you know a specific reason to do it
don't complicate things right and like
matt was saying you you've already
containerized and virtualized that
process right it is isolated so
yeah and and when you would start to use
virtual environments because you're
running two versions of python inside of
a container you start breaking that rule
of uh one process inside of a container
so
yeah
yeah i think i think a really nice thing
about that process stuff and we'll get
to that here is is you can actually ice
like networking stacks and secrets and
environments and there's so many so many
nice pieces of composing these things
together
where
similarly with a virtual environment not
using one it doesn't impact any other
service by having that
right right
and i guess it'd be kind of interesting
like python by default installs globally
whereas like you know if you're in the
javascript ecosystem
it you know puts the known modules next
to your project
um
but
it's just kind of i guess an idiom of
how they work
yeah
so or i guess let's see
so
let's step back for a quick sec so we
did this docker build
uh it shouldn't run against we haven't
changed anything
um
sorry
so nothing changed here um but one thing
you can do like i said it's kind of if
you don't tag it you get this beautiful
shaw which is hard to run um so we just
like
so we can tag it and then docker images
so now we can run these things by
tagging them so instead of the docker
run we had earlier
we can do it here um so this carries
over into
the docker compose file um and this is i
think right now we'll focus on
making the dev experience really really
nice
but all these things translate to when
you go to deploy it
so you can actually
you can set your image here you can set
a name
and this makes it just easy to reference
later docker otherwise gives you a
default name that i don't particularly
care for but
let me step through these once i can
type them
docker file
all right this should fix our bootloop
issue
there's another fun idiom in python if
you don't do a python on buffered
especially in docker and you're
you print something out you expect to
see a standard out it might not show for
a while until it's flushed
so just a funny idiom
all right
let's do this so we actually run it
um
all right and then we have to define so
this is our application itself uh and
now we start thinking dependencies so we
do image
that is
and that's let me add up here
again this is this is this is really
sweet because what we're doing is we're
defining the graph or the relationships
between
between uh our service and what it
depends on our application or when you
do a really complicated thing
it's a bunch of them i think ours at
work is like 220 lines just to run our
dev stuff
let's see secrets i've actually just
started using secrets too
which is pretty fun
yeah oops
like the big reason tell me if i'm wrong
is i think it emulates probably a more
productive environment better and
the secret doesn't like if it's an
environment variable it doesn't end up
in your end image is that correct
yeah correct correct
and it's um
yeah it's a it's a
virtual file system too so it it isn't
really on disk
um but when your container when your
process reads it in it to your process
it looks like a normal file
oh okay
yeah that's that was in the like var run
or whatever
yep
all right let's see this should work
here
and then i need to move
all right so the secrets i'm not gonna
cut out um but those are all like all
the things our app depends on so your
your
client id client secret um
all that kind of stuff database
credentials if it's a remote database
all that
do it live
all right so i guess it does
let's see
what's that
i know it's an environment variable to
use have composed use the new cli stuff
too so i wonder if that's is it a
different cache probably
yeah it's a different um
yeah it's a different environment
variable
good topic it's like cli something
history for the win there we go now we
have to rebuild it cool so what this did
we just booted up the app in docker it's
now running in this container um because
we already have the cache didn't have to
rebuild so that makes kind of some dev
experience really nice you have to keep
reinstalling stuff
um
although we'll show that that's not true
in a second but now it's running using
the
contained redis which is at this host
name
i think this gets into some fun stuff
with compose
kind of for anyone who's unfamiliar we
these by default are going to be kind of
the same network stack which is created
for this
based on this docker files location or
this compose files location um so
network
ls
so you can see it's misspot default so
that's the default network that we're
getting
and as such they are
on the same network and we can actually
resolve this one by its effective host
name
which is pretty neat
and we have to think about ports or any
of that because i think it by default
what it exposes i think is what it would
use
and then you can actually see if this
dude works
quick note on that that network name
the miss bot so that's that's being
pulled from the directory that you're
that you're currently running your
compose file in
so it'll it'll uh so you don't get
clashes if you're running to compose
applications
um it'll preface
uh networks and volumes and stuff like
that with the folder that you're in
oh this gets this goes to our students
all right cool now we actually see the
issue that we we created for ourselves
earlier so because we're these are
isolated networks and misbot is
currently listening on one two seven
zero zero one
we actually can't access it
and that's just because it's not exposed
to our host um it's in that it's in that
private network that network overlay
so we can fix that real quick with
this docker file and this
um
this is kind of a nice way to show how
rebuilds will work because the only
thing we're going to change is this
lines we'll see what else happens
um
oh
okay
this is kind of funny so the reason i
think this is rebuilding and this is
kind of a fun
doctorism uh something to just be aware
of it's not actually bad
um but we need to add you have the stock
grid and aura file and basically what
happens is when docker builds your image
it copies everything from your host into
it and again as python people we
probably have talks we have event we
have obviously our git project all that
gets copied in
um so in the stalker ignore
uh we're ignoring some of those things
because we don't want those copied and
we want them isolated to our host and we
don't want them
we don't want to make what's called like
a fat image at the end where it just
gets just all this extra stuff in
it um
so we probably need to just
do the dark file
i wonder if i can validate the cash on
accident somehow that way
yeah
anyway what's supposed to happen if i
hadn't if i had excluded that this
wouldn't be rebuilding again um i'm
gonna kill that because we're gonna
we're gonna move on to dark file v2
anyway um but it would have only rebuilt
that last line
of the docker file um because nothing
had changed in any of these pieces
uh the only thing that changed here and
docker is pretty smart about
you know this this value is based on the
line uh the contents but when it's a
file it i believe it's based on the
actual like the chat or i guess it's
validated here since the file changed
evaluates all lower layers
uh so in this case it should have just
done this one but um i screwed up with
that doc file which is fine
how dare you
yes
i'm good at messing things up
let's see
and yeah just a quick note it's very
interesting the way that the caching
works too it'll actually like i think
you touched on it real quick so that
requirements production txt it knows
it's a file
and it you know it does uh it'll
actually look in the context in
different kinds of ways
to make sure
um
that the cache was actually validated
i think it looks at time stamps it looks
at uh hashes and stuff like that
looks pretty cool
yeah it's really nice when it works or
when i do it correctly it always pretty
much always works so that was definitely
my error um let's do docker file v2 and
so kind of one thing when i'm talking
about kind of making these fat images
these big honking you know
things you have to ship around
it's it's kind of painful it's like this
one has a lot of stuff in it that we
might not care about for like
development we're installing our
production
um txt our production requirements um
for just dev work and maybe we don't
need all that stuff like
i
don't know i guess you should usually
emulate production so
um
yeah
for for python it's a little harder to
to
um
condense these a little bit because we
don't build a single executable we can
ship off to people
instead of python we build
we install a bunch of packages and we
have to have the ceilings and all that
but like in go you build a
one you just ship that guy but so let's
clean this up
um
and we're gonna use we're gonna use
multi-stage builds for that here
um so we'll make a base image and we're
going to thin this down where
hopefully we actually leverage caching
correctly
so in this case instead of copying
everything let's copy our requirements
to
requirements
so we're going to copy all that
directory so the only reason that this
cash should be invalidated is this
folder
one of our requirements changed
and then
similarly you want to tip install our
requirements
uh expose and this is all probably fine
here
and then from there this is kind of a
decent production image starting point
we could use um
but then we can actually do another
layer which uses our previous
image to build from
as dev and then this we can do some nice
stuff
for the dev experience to
uh our development
development dependencies
and then
um
one of which is tox which i don't put in
my files if taxes install itself
and then we can actually copy the rest
in and
we can use the same
same one but i actually like to add
a flag to this
and again this is one of those nice
things that javascript's had forever and
python didn't quite as much some auto
reloading when files changed
and so that's pretty decent starting
point and then
um
yeah let's see
production
we can do
sorry
copy everything in and that way
it'll just and then this command will be
by default what's happening here because
ready to find it i think
oh sorry
one thing we i forgot to comment on
let's do this
all right so now that we've changed this
image and we're going to rebuild it we
can since we have these these different
layer or these multi stages we can use
uh since we're working on this in dev
we're going to want a couple things
first off is we're going to want
the local
directory
to be at app uh the reason being just we
want all of our current files to be in
uh
in the container
i guess we probably need to misspot but
okay
and then the other big thing is now that
we have a target we can do we don't
always want to run the production way
primarily because
we're gonna we're gonna just have extra
stuff and the stuff we want which is our
development dependencies so pi test and
uh talks and those kind of things won't
be in that final image and it won't
reload um so to make the dev image fun i
like to make this comfortable and usable
we can add the target here
as dev
and then
yeah i did mean volume thank you docker
we're very helpful and friendly here at
docker
i'd say generally the it's nice when it
gives you recommendations get similar
like you'll be like oh did you mean
status instead of stat or something yeah
i did
there's that nice um command line app
i have not used it but a lot of friends
really like it uh i think it's called
the f word and um
it tries to correct previous commands
that failed
i'll have to check that out yeah
it's probably probably a good pick
and similarly this one's going to
probably take a little bit since we
changed the file and compose
or building and compose
so we got a
got a question here
so alexander asked will these config
files be shared anywhere for reference
you're going to put this on
github correct
yup yup i'll get on my github
awesome and that'll be probably tonight
let's see or i guess right for this
okay this is my name pretty boring
and we'll get the we'll get the link
sent out with the recording
yeah that sounds good
let's see
looks like reduce that we froze here are
you are you back on radu
we're okay here anybody else having
troubles just
uh
throw in the questions there
or in the chat you can chat to me but
all right so i think last time was what
140 140 seconds yep
there's a hard part of showing docker
editing too sometimes the builds
you know maybe a small flask gap is
it's a good approach but it's fun to
actually do something you're working on
i think in docker to share that
just reading through some questions
okay brady's back good
yeah it's probably probably was on your
end
hopefully if not if if you get any more
hookups let me know
with everybody uh
everybody at home and at least here in
the united states a lot a lot of kids
are still in virtual school
but they should be it's 3 30 my time
kids are finishing up now
yeah they basically uh
kids are basically like working in
corporate america these days they just
sit on zoom calls
pretty much
yeah i've heard of some have to have to
do their homework on zoom
yeah
i saw a friend of mine tweet out um my
son said oh i don't want to go to school
all i do is sit on zoom calls or i don't
want to sit in zoom calls all day today
and
the dad was like yeah me too
yeah
plug my work i think
we're very good about not having a lot
of calls which is pretty nice
yeah
so xbox is always hiring too i'm sure
like like everyone right now at least
the dev space i should say
this is kind of nice output here um you
can see
what layer it's building so we can see
we're setting up our base layer it's
five different layers to build it
uh used these cache ones from probably
our previous build and added some stuff
um
oh yeah not that sharp
build okay cool so again kind of like i
was saying now when you're doing it
right there's actually caches that's
great
i was gonna say there's the cache right
there
and hopefully
things are working again
there we go cool so our app is now back
up we're listening on the correct
interface you have to listen on zero
zero zero zero um or i guess if you want
to grab the doctor's ip that's fine
probably too
and so now that's back let's
pose so here's a couple things that we
did special i think this target so if
multi-stage builds this is cool
um
and then we're using secrets instead of
the environment for a couple reasons we
talked about it's not it's a virtual
fire file system so it's not
going to be just in the image or on the
on the file system
directly
and this is what's really cool about
secrets you can actually use secrets in
docker build right now um and so if you
want to do that right now like a lot of
people if you're just installing from a
private github you have to put in your
key as a build arg
just authenticate to download but then
it's in the image it's in like the layer
cache you can inspect it that kind of
stuff
with secrets i think they actually don't
do that so you can use it just for a
command at a time and it's not
inspectable so you could actually build
your image with private repositories
uh compile your code if it's a compiled
project and actually ship that to people
without them being able to get your you
know github private deploy key or
whatever you're using
yeah exactly
exactly
that was pretty cool i think it's
something i need to roll out of work
still
um
yeah sure
and two sorry matt yeah um
you know i've seen uh in in a layer in a
docker file you add something that's
sensitive data and then a couple
commands down you delete it
well it's still in your it's still in
the previous layer right and you can
inspect those so
um yeah use secrets as much as possible
keep your keep your clean
yeah i
think come on
yeah i mean you can see
quite a bit like the path the
hip hatch the i mean
there's a lot of information in these
that and i think you can actually
inspect even further um when you have
the layers you actually pulled up
uh so right now
we put we put our app in docker um we
put it in compose we now volume mapped
in our code so now all of a sudden like
all right i want my dev experience to be
good
and so we added reload so let's do
this is this is just me trivial just to
uh get trigger a restart and hopefully
it restarts which it does
so you see up here our bot just reloaded
so this can work for any application
the sports live reloading so if you're
a node person javascript whatever it'll
work there
um
by volume mapping and so since i'm on a
linux kernel in wsl
i think it actually supports like i
notify which is like a nice way to pull
for those changes
so every time you change you don't have
to like kill and restart your app you
have to rebuild doc you have to do any
of that stuff unless you change you know
a base layer so like a we had a
dependency or whatever
um and then even better i think kind of
a nice bonus we can we can tap into
here is all right so now this is just a
yaml file
most things from yaml we can actually
use here so if you're the type of person
that likes to run your tests
every time you change a file
you know you can just use some email
anchors
not i don't know i copied all that
because none of it's actually useful yes
because what we can do
is we're gonna anchor
robot or uh
so now what we're doing is we're saying
hey i want to run another service that
uses all this exact same stuff
and do it again but there's a caveat as
certain things can't work so we have to
do we have to say don't use the ports
um
we do want most environment other than
ssl
so again just using
some some nice uh um
yaml features i know a lot of people
hate yaml a lot of us coding yaml every
day for work half the time
but
we can override some of these so we can
actually run our tests
on live reload so then we can change the
command out and we'll override what was
in our container
which would
be did you
um
that's enough look at notes turned over
i was gonna say it's pretty impressive
if you remember all those
now
actually just
right before we got on here i was like i
should make this do
this because it'd be really useful
all right let's see if this one actually
works
oh the name
yes that's a bad part of naming them by
manually
recreating typed it wrong i'm not sure
i'll tell you her name
i don't know your terminal through is
too fast for me
i think it i think that docker compose
is still running
ah yeah
sorry i do jump around a lot my fault
no no worries
okay let's see if it works this time
all right so
again two images using the shared cache
because it's the same image we're just
we're using our dev dependency one
and this one's already satisfied this
one's built so now we should be able to
get not a live reloading of our of our
of our project
um
but
we can also have our tests run
automatically so every
every time we change something in our
file
these tests run uh it's getting worrying
about our time zone that we're not
configured that's probably something we
should do in the docker file which
probably also set up another user but in
any case
this is now
shareable with your colleagues your
friends open source system whatever so
when i push this ideally speaking any
anyone here that wanted to contribute
could
come on kill it there we go
could literally pull down our project
run this and be off to the race is now
contributing it's a thing about like
leveraging this for your teams at work
or open source now your colleagues like
hey i don't know how to run the project
well this is a way to get started and
then if they want to you know go outside
the realm
of normal they can do that but
oh i think i think this is pretty
awesome it shares you know
configurability
um
run you know the runtime it's pretty
cool and then
what we can do from here
we can leverage docker kind of to do
something
um
kind of something fun so
you can run this using compose on
servers very easily and strip out some
of the stuff we're actually going to
give up
we'll just we'll uh go to one of my
servers real quick
i'll probably change one of these
passwords because i think everyone can
see this but
this is a docker compose i have here
running
and this is to replace if you see this
command
up here
uh what i'm doing is i'm doing i'm
basically replacing ngrok so anyone who
ever has written a bot or anything might
be familiar you have to tcp forward
um you generally have to use an https
hostname or
domain um and to do so you have to do
something like ngrok or something else
so to get around that because i don't
want to pay the money you have to keep
changing my urls i basically set this up
all with docker
on a server where i can port forward
from there
to
my
my computer here so all it does is i
have an open ssh server
that we put forward through and we get
automatic ssl because the way docker
works is the whole run time shares
events and everything
where
um
you can have like automatic tls
created for you for your for your host
name so this is automatically managed
and i could share this with my project
and put in basically anybody's public
key and not feel scared because my
server this is in docker and again we
talk about this isolation it's isolated
from the host it's isolated from other
containers it's isolated from the file
system even so
you know i could give anybody access to
this
and we could i could it doesn't really
matter
because
because you're in an isolated
environment so this is
this is this is all it is
and that's a linux server so we can kill
it by deleting everything but if you did
that it didn't matter
actually you can't because it's not even
root um so this is the nice part about
using the user piece is now we can
isolate like kind of some of our
infrastructure pieces so vpns and state
service and all that
yeah nice
yeah i was kind of a bonus one i thought
i was like that'd be cool if people
could see that because it's pretty
simple
all levers do docker too
yeah i think
we probably look at questions i guess uh
i don't have a ton more i have to have a
few other items if we want to get into
it
yeah
but
think um i think we're all good on
questions if anybody else has a question
uh drop it into the question section
and um
yeah
this has been awesome this is great so
we'll get this like matt said he'll um
push this all up to his repo and so you
can pull it back down
after the after uh recording uh i
believe later tonight you should receive
an email that has a um a link to watch
the recording so if you want to replay
it and clone the repo or fork the repo
and
you know play along right and
see everything that matt has done
and apply some of these to your python
projects right
super helpful and if you want you can
then
tweet at me
let me know you're working on it'd be
cool to see people uh going through the
demo themselves
but yeah if anybody else has any
questions go ahead and drop them into
questions other than that we're uh we're
pretty much done
uh yeah we covered a lot that was super
cool
i i definitely had i'm not a um
you know i program in python but i am um
definitely not a professional python
developer i'm always i can program in
many languages but it's different
programming in a language they're
playing around and doing demos then to
building production world stuff right
someone's actually going to use so i
really appreciate you coming on matt
and uh going through this for us
yeah thanks for having me
glad we could cover quite a quite a few
steps i think in docker and how useful
it is
yeah for sure for sure
well thanks everybody um
yeah i don't think we have any questions
so
you are welcome radu thanks for joining
us thanks for everybody for showing up
look for the replay again uh should be
on your inbox if not tonight definitely
tomorrow
and uh we'll drop in there the github
link
and
yeah thanks everybody really